the reason it is so challenging now is
you know when you're younger It's
relatively easy because you're just
caring for a child aren't you but then
that child grows up and gets bigger and
heavier and then you're caring for an
adult and the whole system changes then
and myself you know I'm 30 years older
than I was when I first started nearly
40 years older and my health needs I
have them as well so that means it makes
it really extremely difficult to
carefully physically you know because it
requires a lot of moving and handling
lifting and moving you know on the bed
to changing get him dressed get them
washed things like that and I'm finding
that really really difficult at the
moment my husband is self-employed so he
can't get time off because if he does
get time off to help me with Lee then he
doesn't get paid
and that's always very difficult you
know the cost of living is going up
isn't it energy bills are rising we do
struggle